[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الى النشره المفصله من العربيه
انا ميسون عزام واحييكم وهذه التاسعه
مشاهدينا نبدا بالعنايه
اوكرانيه
لقطع الامداد عن ميليشيات ايران تقرير ان
يكشف ونيه اسرائيليه لتعطيل المطارات
الرئيسيه في سوريا
[موسيقى]
القضاء الايراني يثبت حكم الاعدام بحق
المتظاهر محمد بروغاني والعفو الدوليه
تدعو طهران لالغاء العقوبه
البرلمان الليبي يعلن تكلفه فريق قانوني
للدفاع عن ابو عجيل المشتبه به بقضيه
لقربي
[موسيقى]
اذا المشاهدين 63 مجندا روسيا قتلوا
باربعه صواريخ
اوكرانيه سقطت على معسكر تجنيد مؤقت في
منطقه
طبعا هذه الحصيله هي بحسب وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه لكن الروايه الاوكرانيه مغايره
تماما رئاسه الاركان تبنت الهجوم رسميا
لكنها قالت ان عدد قتل القذف من الجنود
الروس بلغ حوالي 670 جنديا اين نتحدث عن
حوالي 10 اضعاف الحصيله التي اعلنت عنها
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه اما عن السبب الذي
ادى الى سقوط هذا العدد الكبير فهو
استخدامه مجندين روسي لحواتهم الامر الذي
كشف مواقعهم للجيش الاكرانيا
[موسيقى]
كيف تبرمجمه
امريكيه الصنع على مركز انتشار مؤقت
للمجندين الروس في منطقه ماكفيكا بجمهوريه
دانيتك دفعتنا الجويه
روسيا وسنقوم بتقديم كل الدعم لعائلتي
واقارب قتل الهجوم
ليفربول
الامريكي قال في تقييمه للحرب الدائره في
اوكرانيا قال ان القوات الروسيه تستنفذ
مخزوناتها من ذخيره المدفعيه مما سيجعل من
الصعب عليها الحفاظ على الوتيره العاليه
للعمليات في بخمه واماكن اخرى في اوكرانيا
كان رئيس جهاز المخابرات العسكريه
الاوكرانيه قد صرح بان القوات الروسيه في
اوكرانيا تعاني جراء نقص ذخيره المدفعيه
وقال ان القوات الروسيه كانت تستخدم سابقا
60,000 قذيفه مدفعيه يوميا الان تستخدم 19
الى 20,000 قديفه فقط اكد رئيس المخابرات
الاوكرانيه ان مدى المئزق الروسي سيطضح
بصوره اكبر بحلول مارس 20 23 اي هذا العام
هجوم عابر للحدود على اوكرانيا انطلاقا من
بيلاروسيا هو احتمال لم يعد مستبعدا ابدا
في ظل التطورات الحاليه وايضا تقدم الجيش
الاوكراني على الارض كييف عبر وزاره
الدفاع يتوقعت اي يشهد شهر فبراير محاوله
غزو روسيه جديده للاراضي الاوكرانيه لم
تستبعد ان تكون الاراضي البيلاروسيا نقطه
انطلاق هذه الحمله احتمال سبقتها في
الاستخبارات الاوكرانيه ايضا والتي حذرت
من ان التهديد بغزو شمالي ثامن طبعا
بالرغم من انه منخفض الا انه يبقى ممكنا
وغير مستبعدا خصوصا لتخفيف الضغط عن
الجبهات في الشرق وايضا في الجنوب
احتمالات اشار اليها لا بل وحذر منها
الامين العام لحلف الناتو قائلا ان
الدلاله لا تشير الى ان موسكو تستعد لشنه
هجوم برج جديد واسع نطاق داعيا اوكرانيا
الى الاستعداد لصراع طويل الامد
[موسيقى]
المزيد معنا من ثياب حذيفه عادل مراسل
العربيه اهلا بك حذيفه في ظل التصريحات من
اكياب حول امكانيه التدخل
البيلاروسي وتحريك هذه الجبهه كيف تستعد
روسيا هل من تلمس اوكرانيا بالاحرى هل من
تلمس لاي استعدادات معينه في العاصمه
تحياتي ميسون يعني للاسف الصوت يتقطع
قليلا لم اسمع ولم افهم الجبهه تحديدا
التي تتحدثين عنها كيف اعلنت واستخباراتها
اكدت بان هناك امكانيه كبيره ربما تكون
ضئيله ولكن هناك امكانيه بان يكون هناك
تحرك من بيلاروسيا بمعنى اخر نحن نتحدث عن
توسعه
خارطه الميدانيه وتحركها هل من استعدادات
ملموسه على الارض لمثل هذا التهديد
والخيال
صحيح
ونسبه لذلك قامت كيف بكثير من الاجراءات
والتجهيزات على مدى الشهرين والثلاثه اشهر
الماضيه بعد ان نتبين لها ان القوات
الروسيه قامت بتحريك قوات من داخل الاراضي
الروسيه من شبه جزيره القرم وايضا بعض
القوات التي تم سحبها من خرسون ايضا تم
الحقها بالقوات في الحدود الروسيه اذا
هنالك تجمع للقوه وللمعدات وهنالك عمليات
تدريب وايضا طبعا هنالك بعض الاستفزازات
التي تحدث من فتره الى اخرى في الحدود
الاوكرانيه الروسيه لذلك قامت اولا بانشاء
جدار او بتشييد جدار فاصل بين الحدود
الفعل الروسيه والاكرانيه الحقت هذا
الجدار الفاصل بعض المجاري للمياه وكذلك
قامت بعمليه زرع للالغام واسعه على الحدود
وكثفت من تواجد حرص الحدود على الحدود
الروسيه على الروسيه قبل ايام قليله لا لا
اللواء فيكتور وهو قائد الاداره الشماليه
كان قد تفقد الحدود واطمان على يعني او
الاوضاع في الحدود كذلك ارسلت اكيف اللواء
58 والذي كان يقاتل في شرير بعد ذلك تحرك
للقتال في الشرق الان هو موجود على الحدود
البيروسيه الروسيه في هذا المثلث ايضا
الدفاعات تلك المنطقه
باعتبار ان السيناري سيكون اجتياح بري هذا
ما يقال لانه اخر فتره صارت المسيرات هي
الطريقه المثلى لاداره هذه الحرب
صحيح كيف تقول انها جاهزه لكل سيناريوهات
الاجتهاد البري هو احد الخيارات المتوقعه
تعلمين ان الحدود البلاروصيه تبعد حوالي
ثلاث ساعات يعني الاكثر من العاصمه كيف في
بعض المناطق ساعتين فقط يمكن الوصول الى
تخومه العاصمه كيف لذلك هي اا حدود هامه
جدا ولذلك خالد بتعزيز قد قام قد دخل منها
القوات الروسيه من قبل في الاتجاه الاول
في الرابع والعشرين ولذلك قامت بعمليه هذه
التعزيزات وهي تتوقع ان يكون هناك هجوم
بري كذلك انظمه الدفاع تم نشرها خاصه في
المثلث الجنوبي الشرقي وايضا تم نشرها في
الاتجاه الشمالي وكذلك في الاتجاه الشرقي
كما هنالك مضادات في العاصمه كيف احول
العاصمه كيف طبعا لاي عمليات همم قصف او
مسيراته العسكريه انه مثل هذا الاشتياح
اذا ما حدث هو للتخفيف عن الجبهات الاخرى
اعاده الانتشار همم الاوكرانيه الان هل
لها بالفعل ان من قوه الجانب الاوكراني في
تلك الجبهات المشتريعه الى الان او لا
الجيش الاوكراني بشكل واضح وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني الرئيس الاوكراني المستشاري
الرئيس تحدث عن ذلك بشكل واضح وقالوا ان
لدينا عدد كافي جدا من الجنود ومن الجنود
الاحتياطيين النقص الوحيد الذي يمكن ان
يكون هو في المعدات وفي الاليات وفي انظمه
الدفاع الجوي وكذلك في المدفعيه وهذا
الامر جرى العمل عليه في شهرين الماضيين
بكثافه مع الدول الصديقه لاوكرانيا وملحت
اوكرانيا عدد من المدفعيه وعدد من الاسلحه
والان هم يقولون لهم مطمئنون تماما طبعا
حتى ان هنالك في الجنود لا يجدون سلاحا
كما قال قبل همم الرئيس الاوكراني قال ان
لدينا من الجيش الاحتياطي ما يكفي ويزيد
عن حاجاتنا لذلك نحن مطمئنونه تماما من
هذا الجاني الوضع العسكري بالنسبه للجيش
الاوكراني هو طبعا كما قالوا ولن يؤثر على
الجبهات في الشرق او في الجنوب على الاسهم
يقولون ان الاتحاد الروسي هو الذي يعاني
لذلك قام باعلان التعبئه وايضا هنا
معلومات استخباراتيه تقول انه في الايام
القليله القادمه سوف يقوم الاتحاد الروسي
باغلاق الحدود في وجه كل الرجال دون
الخامسه والخمسين
العربيه شكرا جزيلا لك
طبعا في هذا الاطار نعود للاستهداف اليوم
ضربه قويه من اوكرانيا لروسيا من خلال
استهدافها لمعسكر للمجندين معي عبر سكايب
من دونيسك رائد الاخضر مراسل العربيه رائد
الارقام هناك فارق كبير وشاسع ما بين
الارقام الاوكرانيه فيما يتعلق بالضحايا
اوكرانيا تتحدث عن اكثر من 600 ايه قتيل
تم تحديدهم من الروس المجندين وروسيا
تتحدث عن همم رقم 63 او البعض يقول انه
ارتفع هذا الرقم ولكن قليلا هل من جهه
محايده يمكن تاكيد الارقام من عدمها
ميسون بالفعل هناك تباين كبير بالرقمين
المطروحين من قبل الدفاع الروسيه والدفاع
الاوكرانيه لكن دعينا يعني نطرح ال يعني
الارقام التي يعني يعلن عنها المرصد
المحلي هنا في دانيت كالمصد المحلي قال
بان اعداد القتلى الان ارتفع الى
78 قتيل بينما هناك اصابات حوالي 136
اصابه في المستشفى لكن الاهم من ذلك ان
هناك اعداد كبيره تحت الانقاذ وما زالت
يعني وزاره الطوارئ يعملون للبحث عن ناجين
من تحت الانقاذ والمنطقه همم مغلقه
بالكامل ولم يسمح لنا بالدخول الى هذه
المنطقه ميسون
منعتنا هل من تبرير رائد او قراءه لاسباب
هذا العدد الكبير بغض النظر ان كان همم 80
او 70 او حتى 600 عدد كبير يعتبرغ ضربه
قويه لروسيا هل من تبرير كيف همم وصل هذا
العدد الى هذا الحاد كيف تم استهداف هذا
المعسكر بهذه السهوله والطريقه
ايضا قال بان عن شهود عيان من الجنود
الذين
تدربوا او يعني تلقوا بدايه خدمتهم في هذا
المركز هو مركز
لتجميد القادمين بعد التعبئه الجزئيه التي
اعلنتها روسيا هو يستقبل حيث تقال احد
القاده في مقاطعه
في مقاطعه في احدى المقاطعات الروسيه اظن
مقاطع قراءه قراءه
عدد من الجنود الذين
[موسيقى]
يعني قتلوا في هذه الضربه العسكريه لكن
الحديث عن حوالي 300 شخص [__] هذا المركز
ما بين مدني وعسكري هذه التصريحات التي
يعني اطلقها المرصد المحلي هنا وهو مصر
مرصد رسمي من قبل السلطات المحليه لكن
اعداد الضحايا تزداد مع همم يعني هناك
حالات حرجه في المشفى وايضا هناك منهم تحت
الانقاض همم يعني العمليه العسكريه تمر
بمراحل خطره نحن نقف الان في هذا المباشر
والقسم مستمر يقع تقع الصواريخ وتسقط من
حولنا في المدينه ميسون حقيقه نحن يجب ان
نتعجل في اخراج هذه حتى لا نقف طويلا في
الشارع همم
[موسيقى]
طيب يمكننا ان ننهيه الان اييي اهم شيء
الان حياتكم طبعا وامكم شكرا كثير عبر
سكايب من دونيسك رائد الاغبر مراسل
العربيه نتمنى لكم السلامه
[موسيقى]
التي تطلقها روسيا وتفعيل الدفاعات الجويه
الاخرانيه مشهدا مالوفا في سماء العاصمه
لا فرق بين عام جديد وعام مضى انها الحرب
التي اقتربت من طي عامها الاول
غارات روسيه مره اخرى ضربت البنيه التحتيه
للطاقه في كييف ومحيطها تسببت معها
بانقطاع واسع للتيار الكهربائي عن العاصمه
وعده
مناطقون يمكنكم الشعور بهذا وهم محقون في
الخوف لانه ماس يهزمون الطائرات بدون طيار
والصواريخ وكل شيء اخر لن يساعدهم لاننا
نقف متحدين هم فقط يوحدهم الخوف ولن يسلب
استقلانا
الهجمات الروسيه طالت كذلك مناطق اخرى
كدنبرو وبترو بيسكو وزباروجيا حيث اسقطت
الدفاعات الاوكرانيه تسعه سيارات روسيه
ايرانيه الصنع لكن رغم الخسائر الفادحه
التي لحقت بالبنيه التحتيه في اوكرانيا
الا ان وحدات الجيش تؤكد ان نسب النجاح في
التصدي للهجمات الروسيه ارتفعت الى نحو
80% قسط وافر من ذلك يعود للدعم والتصليح
الغربي
انس نماسي العربيه
حول الطائرات الروسيه التي اسقطت في سماء
اوكرانيا طبعا هؤلاء يزعمون ان كل
الطائرات الروسيه تقريبا والتي تم اسقاطها
عمليات وقعت بالخطا بواسطه انظمه الدفاع
الجوي لموسكو نفسها فهل فعلا انظمه
الدفاعات الجويه الروسيه باتت العدو الاول
والابرز لسلاح الجو الروسي في خانه ما وصف
بالنيران طبعا الصديقه اكد العسكريون
الروس ان قواتهم فشلت احيانا في التفاعل
وبقاء التواصل ما بين فروعها ما ادى الى
سقوط طائرات مقاتله من طراز امبيرتي سو 34
سوا بالاضافه الى ايضا مروحيات 52
وبالفعل اصدرت القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه
بيانات عده على مدى الاشهر الماضيه اكدت
فيها ان روسيا اسقطت بعد طائراتها بالخطا
اخرها الاسبوع الماضي علما بان موقع اوركس
الذي يتتبع الخسائر الجانبين اكد فقدان 63
طائره روسيه وما يمثلها عددا من المروحيات
اما هيئه الاركان العامه للقوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه فحددت خسائر موسكو من طائرات
الهليكوبتر
ب280 طائره والمقاتلات نتحدث عن 200 و 283
طائره حربيه منذ بدايه الحرب في فبراير
الماضي بحسب تقرير صادر عن معهد بريطاني
فان النيران الصديقه هي واحده من اكبر
المشاكل التي قودت العمليه العسكريه
لروسيا في اوكرانيا وعنوانها الابرز طبعا
الافتقار الملحوض للاتصالات
[موسيقى]
وفي محاوله القبض على سته هاربين من
معسكرات بادنر للتدريب حذرت السلطات
الروسيه سكان مدينه يروس دوفاندون من خطر
العناصر الهاربه سلطات الروسيه وزعت
منشورات في ارجاء المدينه مطالبه السكان
بمراعاه التدابير السلامه الشخصيه والى
اهتمام خاص بالاشخاص الذين يرتدون الزي
العسكري وكان المدن دون سته الذين تحولوا
الى مرتزقه فروا من مركز تدريب في الثاني
والعشرين من ديسمبر الماضي رجح مراقبون ان
يكون هؤلاء ضمن مجموعه المجندين الاخيره
التي جمعتها فادنر من السجون مقابله وعدهم
بالعفو علما بان القتل هو عقاب الفارين
وقد نفذتهم موسكو في نوفمبر الماضي بعد
نشر مقطع فيديو لضرب راس مرتزق
بمطرقه ثقيله
جبتهم
اليوم
[موسيقى]
الجديد استهدفت الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه مواقع عسكريه لنظام الاسد
وميليشيات ايران وبالتالي بكوره الغارات
الاسرائيليه على سوريا في 20 23 القصف
استهدف مستودعا للاسلحه والذخيره تابعه
للمليشيات الايرانيه لنظام الاسد داخل
مطار دمشق وموعدات لوجستيه وصلت حديثا
للمليشيا في محيط هذا المطر قصف اسفل عن
سقوط قتله من الميليشيات الايرانيه وايضا
ضابط للنظام السوري كانوا متواجدين داخل
بمحيط مطار دمشق الذي بات الهدف الاول
للغارات الاسرائيليه الغارات الاسرائيليه
دمرت ايضا قد رجا كانت تستخدمه الطائرات
الايرانيه لنقل الاسلحه والميليشيات
واخرجت المطار عن الخدمه وذلك لساعات قبل
ان يعود للعمل مجددا
[موسيقى]
اذا المشاهدين المطارات السوريه بنك
الاهداف الاول للغارات الجويه الاسرائيليه
السبب طبعا معروف النشاط الايراني
المتمركز وذلك عبر تلك المطارات ولذلك
تبذل اسرائيل كل الجهود العسكريه لتعطيل
وشن المطارات الرئيسيه في سوريا بقطع طريق
امداد مليشيات ايران سينما فيلق القدس
هناك صحيفه نيزافي الروسيه الشهيره كشفت
في تقرير لها عن عزم اسرائيل منع عوده
الحركه الجويه بين روسيا سوريا عذرا
وايران نهائيا لان المسارات تستخدم لنقل
الاسلحه الصحيفه اوضحت ان المسؤولين
الاسرائيليين يستكشفون خيارات مختلفه بما
فيها تعطيل المطارات السوريه باعتبار ان
ايران لجات للمطارات المدنيه لنقل الاسلحه
الى منشياتها بسبب خوفها من نقلها بريا
وفيما يتعلق باليه تنفيذ التهديد
الاسرائيلي نقلت صحيفه الروسيه المسؤولين
اسرائيليين ان ابسط نهج سيكون هو في ضرب
طائرات مهام اير اثناء وجودها على الاراضي
السوريه لكن النظر الى تاثير عمليه من هذا
النوع في مطارات مدنيه يدفع الاسرائيليين
للتفكير بخيارات اختراق البناء التحتيه
للمطار هذا يكون عن طريق تعطيل المطار
المدني باستهداف المحطات الراداريه او
محطات الارشاد والتوجيه اللاسلكي في
المطار ما يحول الطائره الى طائره عمياء
في الجو خيار يعتبر مفيد اكثر من ضرب
المدرج لان اصلاح الاخير لا يتطلب وقتا
طويلا اما ضرب المحطات الراداريه فيتطلب
جلب محطات جديده من روسيا كون المحطات
الحاليه الروسيه ما يعني اخراج المطار عن
الخدمه لفتره اطول بحسب خبراء طيران سوريا
[موسيقى]
المزيد معنا من الرياض العميد اسعد عوض
الزعبي المحل العسكري السوري اهلا بك عميد
اسعد اسمح لي ان ابدا بضربه اليوم وان
كانت مفيده او مجديه او غير مجديه البعض
يقول وبحسب هذا التقرير انه هذه الضربات
لمدارج المطار ربما بسبب اعاده عمل المطار
بسرعه لاقعد مجديه بالنسبه للجانب
الاسرائيلي
مساء الخير يعني اولا عندما نتحدث حقيقه
عن ضربه اليوم هي مجدي من حيث الناس
استهدفت شحنه الاسلحه التي كانت قد وصلت
الى المطار وبنفس الوقت ايضا ربما كان
هناك 30 مباشره على صاله الركاب اعتبار ان
شحنه كانت بالقرب منها لكن يعني بالتاكيد
وايضا هناك كان عدد من قتل يعني ما وصلنا
اخبار هناك ثمانيه قتلى منهم ثلاث ضباط من
النظام وهناك عناصر تابع الميليشيات
وعشرات الجرحى وهناك يعني تعتيم كامل من
قبل قوات النظام خاصه
نفذت الساعه الثانيه بعد منتصف الليل
اعاده عمل همم المطار كما كان الوضع عليه
سابقا
لا لا يعني بالتاكيد بالنسبه للضحايا لانه
عمليه نقل الضحايا باتجاه مشافي الرسول
الاعظم او مشفى الخميني او مشفى المشفى
العسكريه كانت بشكل يعني سري ومنعت حتى
يعني سيارات الاسعاف من ان تشغل ان انتم
او تعطي للناس ان كان هناك من مستيقظين
الهدف من العمليه قد نفذ بالفعل ونجحت
اسرائيل بما تريد ام انه لا بالفعل كما
يقول التقرير تحتاج الان بان تبحث خيارات
اخرى
لا هو هدف تكتيكي بالتاكيد هذا ليس ليس
الهدف الاسرائيلي الهدف الاسرائيلي هو منع
ايران من نقل الاسلحه وهذا لا يتم بهذه
الطريقه بالمناسبه اخراج المطار اليوم لم
يتم اخراج المطار بذكر مانع يعني عاده بكل
قواعد الطيران عندما هناك يكون تحليق
للطيران معادي في الاجواء
او غاره جويه على على مطار احدى المطارات
سيتم اغلاق كل المطارات وبالتالي اغلاق
اغلاق المطار تم يعني حنيا ربما لا يتجاوز
ساعه او اقل من ساعه انما عندما تتحدث
اسرائيل عن الغاء او يعني مانع ايران من
نقل الاسلحه عبر المطارات فهذا بالنسبه
للسوريه
محطات الرادار كما ذكر يعني في تقريركم
نعم انا مدمر المحطات الرادار او الهبوط
الالي او المساعدات الملاحيه افضل من ان
ادمر المهبل او او برج المراه قبل لان ذلك
يمنع الطائر لكن من خصوصيات الطيران
المدني الايراني عفوا انه يستطيع الهبوط
بكل مطارات سوريه يعني لدينا في سوريا 18
مطار منها اربع مدنيات لكن الطيران
الايراني له ممثل جوزي في كل المطار
وبالتالي يعني ايران لا خصوصيه انها
تستطيع نفوت في كل المطارات المدنيه
لا لان ايضا ايران لا تنقل السلاح فقط
بشركه ماهان او بشركات الايرانيه هناك اذا
تنقل بشركات اجنحه الشام او شركه سوريه
للطيران وبالتالي اذا ان دمرت مهان او
شركات ايرانيه لا استفيد او ربما اقلل من
عمليه انما العمل الوحيد فقط هو يعني
تدمير كل المطارات التي يمكن للطيران
ايراني ان يهبط فيه من حلب الى دير الزور
الى حماه ابو ظهور تيفور الناصريه
المطار الدولي ضمير كل هذه المطارات
الطيران الايراني يهبط فيها وكل هذه
المطارات تم بها من خلالها نقل اسلحه
ولذلك عمليه اخراج مطار الدولي سواء بدمشق
قوي حلب احيانا النظام يلجا الى طريقه
الكذب بان المطار اخرج من اجل ان يعطي
رساله الى مديريه الطيران المدينه
العالميه او من اجل ان يعطي رساله لوقف
الهجمات على هذا المطار مع عمليا المطار
لا يتم اخراجه ولا بالطرق التي تستخدمها
اسرائيل حاليا
العسكريه شكرا جزيلا لك
التاسعه ولكن بعد قليل
لتمديد بنتهاكات الطالبان بحق النساء
نشطاء يحتاجون امام البيت الابيض
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
بمنع ايران من الحصول على قدرات نوويه
عسكريه وان اسرائيل ستعمل على تطوير
القدراتها لمواجهه اي سيناريو ايراني
مدينه اسرائيل ملتزمه بمنع ايران من
الحصول على قدره النوويه عسكريه باي وسيله
على خلفيه الاجماع الدوليه على ان الاتفاق
النووي مع ايران لم يعد جدول سنركز على
جانب تعزيز القدرات الامنيه المستقله لاي
سيناريو في محاوله لتشكيل جبهه دوليه لمنع
البرنامج النووي الايراني ان تصرفات ايران
لا تنعكس فقط في طموحها لامتلاك اسلحه
النوويه بل تنعكس ايضا في مشروع الصواريخ
بعيده المدام مثل الطائرات بدون طيار
وتمويل الارهاب الدولي ويجب على دول
العالم ان تتوقف عن دفن رؤوسها في الرمال
اسرائيليه ان ايضا لا تخفي دوائر
استراتيجيه وامنيه هناك القلق من امكان ان
تشهد العلاقه بين البيت الابيض توترات على
خلفيه هيمنه وزراء متطرفين على اجنده
حكومه بنيامين نتنياهو الجديده ويقود في
حال انفجار الوضع مع الفلسطينيين الى
زعزعه الدعم الامريكي لتل ابيب حتى فيما
يتعلق بمواجهه الملف الايراني
الجديده بخصوص استمرار الغارات على ما
تسميه اسرائيل على الايراني في سوريا او
مواجهه المشروع النووي
الايرانيات سود دوائر امنيه واستراتيجيه
اسرائيليه من ان يقود وجود متطرفين في
الحكومه الى اشعال مواجهه مع الفلسطينيين
ما قد يؤثر على العلاقه مع الاداره
الامريكيه الديمقراطيه حتى في التعاون على
مواجهه ايران
لعمليه التي تحدثنا عنها والتي نحذر منها
عمليه تهديد الدعم الامريكي الاوتوماتيكي
لاسرائيل على المدى الطويل واحتمال المسي
بالعلاقات الخاصه مع الامريكيين وفي
الخلفيه انتقادات الديمقراطيين لنتنياهو
ورغم ان اسرائيل اجرد مناورات فرديه واخرى
مشتركه مع الامريكيين ودول اخرى حاكه
استهداف المنشات النوويه الايرانيه الى ان
القدره العسكريه علشان هجوم اسرائيليا
منفرد لم تكتمل بعد معضله اسرائيل ان
استراتيجيتها باتت عالقه منعت الاتفاق
النووي مع ايران لكن بدون وجود خطه دوليه
او حتى اسرائيليه جاهزه بينما تهرب ودود
طهران نحو القنبله النوويه تخصيبا
لليورانيوم
بين الاداره الامريكيه وهمم اسرائيل في
نظرها الى الملف الايراني والى طريقه
التعامل مع هذا التهديد علاقه نتنياه
الفاتره باداره بيد وتشكيكه فيها بتاكيده
مؤخرا فقط بانه لن يشاركها امر الضربه لا
خشيه من تسريب الامر لمنعها قد يترك
اسرائيل وحدها في المواجهه الى حد كبير ثم
ادراك استراتيجيه في اسرائيل بان استهداف
المنشات النوويه الايرانيه يحتاج دعما
وتسليح النوعيه الامريكيه لتنفيذه بنجعه
والا فان التلويحه بالضرب يصبح تلويحا
بمسدس فارغ من الطلقات زياد حلب العربيه
القدس الغربيه
[موسيقى]
الى داخل الايراني حيث يواصل النظام
محاولات ترهيب المحتاجين القضاء الايراني
اعلنا تثبيت حكم الاعدام بحق المتظاهر
محمد برغني بعد توجيهتهم بين نشر الشباب
والفوضى واثاره الظاهر لدى الناس وايضا
احراق مبنى حكومي في مدينه بغداد جنوب
شرقي طهران العاصمه قرار سرعان ما علقت
عليه منظمه العفو الدوليه داعيه طهران الى
التراجع عن حكم الاعدام بحق المتظاهر
وفورا
هذا واحرقه محتجون في عدد من المدن
الايرانيه صورا لقاسم سليمان عشيه الذكرى
الثالثه لمقتله متابعه
سبونج بوب
الايرانيه الصحفي مهدي قديما بعد ان قامت
باقتحام منزل والده في منطقه فرديس بمدينه
كرش بحسب احد افراد العائله فان حوالي 10
من رجال الامن توجهوا صباح امس الى المنزل
وفتشوا غرفته وسيارته الشخصيه وصادرها
هاتفه وحاسوبه المحمول بحسب هذا العضو في
اسره قديم فقد تم اخذ كاميرا المراقبه
الخاصه بمحل سكن الاسره من قبل رجال الامن
واضاف انه بعد فتره وجيزه من القاء القبض
على مهدي قديم فقد نقل الى طهران لان
الضباط كانوا يحملون حكمه الانتقال الصادر
من طهران اشار ايضا الى ان الفرع الذي
يتعامل مع قضيه مهدي القديمه هو الفرع
اثنين من مكتب العام في سجن ايفين وتابع
يقول انه تم اليوم تقديم وثيقه الكفاله
الى مكتب المدعي العام في ايفين لكنهم
قالوا ان موعد تحديد الكفاله لم يتحدد بعد
وفي ملفات ايران ايضا ولكن هذه المره
النوويه قال مندوب روسيا لدى المنظمات
الدوليه في فيينا ميخائيل اوليانوف قال ان
اي بديل عن الاتفاق النووي مع ايران قد
تكون له اثار سلبيه للغايه على الامن
الاقليمي واضاف ان هناك طرق دبلوماسيه
موثوقه للتحقق ممن هو طرف الجاد في
الاتفاق النووي ومن ليس كذلك اشار المندوب
الروسي الى ان الجهود الدبلوماسيه لم
تستنفذ بعد على وجود الاراده السياسيه
المتعلقه بملف الاتفاق النوويه
[موسيقى]
اعلنت البحريه الفرنسيه انها ضبطت اربعه
اطنان من المخدرات عباره عن نصف طن من
الهروين وثلاثه اطنان ونصف من القمه عندما
قامت باعتراض قارب لا يرفع علما في بحر
العرب قالت القياده البحريه لمنطقه المحيط
الهندي مقرها ابوظبي قالت انه تم ضبط
المخدرات التي تقدر قيمتها ب 50 مليون
يورو بعد ان قامت فرقه فرنسيه باعتراض
القارب في السابع والعشرين من ديسمبر
الماضي
[موسيقى]
نظم عدد من النشاطات مظاهره حاشده في
العاصمه واشنطن امام البيت الابيض رفضا
لحضر طالبان النساء الافغانيات من دخول
الجامعه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
من راى منكم من طرف فليغيره بيده فان لم
يستطيع فبسمتي
[موسيقى]
بلكونه خلق الارض
[تصفيق]
مختلفه في العقود الاربعه الماضيه وكانت
قضيه المراه من المواضيع الجده في كل هذه
الانظمه حيث تم التعامل مع حقوق المراه
وتعليمها كاداه سياسيه للجماعات التي
حاربت من اجل السلطه او للبقاء فيها
صالحه تخرجت من جامعه كابول قبل 35 عاما
في عهد الرئيس الاسبق نجيب الله تقول انها
وزميلاتها كنا يدرسن في فصول مشتركه مع
الفتيان في وقت كانت الحريه تسود الاجواء
التعليميه ان ذلك وخاصه زي الفتيات
اكرامي
كما كانت المراه تستطيع ان تختار تخصصها
في جميع المجالات المتاحه دون ان يدعوائق
اما شقيقه صالحه فقد التحقت بجامعه كابول
بعد عامين من صالحه ولكنها لم تستطع
مواصله الدراسه جراء ظروف عسكريه تضيف ان
المراه الافغانيه قد ظلمت قديما وحديثا
بدرجات مختلفه
فقد تم القضاء على عمليه دراستهن وتدريسهن
في البلد
التي تخرجت منها صالح اكبر واشهر جامعه في
افغانستان والتي تم تاسيسها سنه
1930 ميلاديه قدمت الالاف من الخريجات في
تخصصات مختلفه الى المجتمع الافغاني
المسيره الطويله في رحله تعليم الفتيات لن
تتوقفها فالمجتمع الافغاني وعلى الرغم من
الازمات المتلاحقه تظل رغبه الافغان
بمستقبل لا يكون فيه التعليمه حجر الزاويه
عبد الله نادر العربيه كابول
في التاسعه ولكن بعد قليل
اعداد المهاجرين غير الشرعيه عبر بحر
المانش يزدادوا 150 ضعفا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مجددا الى التاسعه قال المتحدث
باسم مجلس النواب الليبي عبد الله بليق
قال ان البرلمان قرر مخاطبه السلطه
القضائيه لتكليف فريق قانوني للدفاع عن
ابو عجيله المريمي المجتمع به في قضيه
الكربه والذي جرى تسليمه الى واشنطن الشهر
الماضي واضاف بلحق ان البرلمان قرر ايضا
خلال جلسته المنعقده اليوم اضافه ماده في
القرار الذي اقره مجلس النواب حول قضيه
ابو عجيله بحيث يتم تحصين ومنع تسليم اي
مواطن لي بمستقبل لايجها
[موسيقى]
في تونس عمده موظفوا شركه النقل الحكوميه
في تونس العاصمه الى اضراب عام الاضراب
ياتي احتجاجا على التاخير في دفع الاجور
والمكافات مما ادى الى شلل في حركه السير
واغلاق الطرق وتعطيل حركه المترو الاضراب
المفتوح دعت اليه نقابه النقل التركيز على
المشاكل الماليه التي تواجه الشركات
العامه المقبله على الافلاس بالتزامن مع
الازمه الماليه التي تعيشها حكومه الرئيس
قيس سعيد
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
هم كانوا يضربوا في الشارع
التيران
مع تمام
كيفك كيفك
اعلنت مصر عن استعادتي تابوت اثري اطلق
عليها التابوت الاخضر من الولايات المتحده
ويعود غطاء التابوت للعصر المتاخر بدايه
من الاسره 27 او بدايه العصر البطلمي
ووزنه نصف طن وفق تحليل الامين العام
الحالي للمجلس الاعلى للاثار مصطفى وزيري
الوزير قال ان بعض اجزاء التابوت في حاله
سيئه وسيحتاج الى ترميم بسبب خروجه بطريقه
غير مشروعه كما اشار وزير الخارجيه المصري
سامح شكري ان استعاده التابوت تمثل ثمره
جهد بين مصر وامريكا في مجال السعاده
الاثار المهربه
الاستعاده التابوت الاخضر وعودته الى ارض
الوطن تمثل حلقه جديده في سلسله نجاحات
جهود وزاره الخارجيه في حمايه ارث مصر
الحضاري وانعكاسا لروحه التعاون التي جمعت
مصر والولايات المتحده الامريكيه في مجال
حمايه الممتلكات الثقافيه واستعاده
الاثار المهربه
يعني اذا لسه في قاعده بس قاعده لصوص
المقابر شافوا ان الغطاء اسهل في شلته في
في نقله في الى اخره فواضح ان الغطا هو بس
اللي اتسرق لكن البيس موجود في مكان الحفر
الخلسه اللي طلع منه هذا العطاء سمي
بالتابوت او بغطاء التابوت الاخضر عشان
اللون ده
اللون ده لون مميز جدا وحساس جدا اللون
الاخضر عند المصري القديم
في سوريا ذكر البنك المركزي انه تم خفض
سعر الصرف الرسمي للعمله المحليه لتصل
قيمه الليره السوريه الى
4522 للدولار الامريكي في حين يبلغ سعر
السوق السوداء المستخدم في معظم الانشطه
الاقتصاديه 6500 وذلك اثر الازمه
الاقتصاديه التي تعاني منها البلاد
الناجمه عن الصراع المستمر منذ سنوات حيث
كان سعر الليره 47 للدولار الامريكي قبل
بدايه الازمه السوريه
[موسيقى]
الى بريطانيا وملف اللاجئين ترتفع ارقام
الهجره عبر بحر المانش سناء بعد اخرى
لتتضعف بعد ذلك رغم الاجراءات
المتشدده للحد منها ورغم الخطط المتعاقبه
للحكومه البريطانيه المحافظه لمكافحه هذه
الظاهره الحساسه سياسيا خصوصا مع فرنسا
حكومه سوناتا تصر على المضيق قدما بخطط
ترحيل المهاجرين الى رواندا الاحصائيات
الرسميه ابهرت زياده اعداد المهاجرين
الذين يقطعون بحر المانش بقوارب صغيره
بشكل غير قانوني الى الاراضي البريطانيه
بمقدار 150 ضعفا وذلك خلال السنوات
الاربعه الماضيه قام اكثر من خمسه واربعين
الف و700 شخص برحلات محفوفه بالمخاطر عبر
القناعه عام 2022 ما يعني زياده بنسبه 60%
عن عام 2021 الذي شهد عبور حوالي 28,000
و500 مهاجر غير شرعي علما بان الرقم لم
يتعدى 1800 شخص عام 2000 2019 العام
الماضي سجل ايضا اكبر عدد من الاشخاص
الذين عبروا قناه المانش في يوم واحد ووصل
عددهم الى
1295 شخص متجاوزا الرقم القياسي السابق
الذي قرب ال 1200 شخص في نوفمبر 2021
[موسيقى]
لما جيت انضم الينا من لندن عروض عبد الحق
مراسله العربيه اهلا بك عروب بدايه هل من
تفسير لهذا الارتفاع المهول في اعداد
المهاجرين غير الشرعيه الى بريطانيا
مرحبا ميسون بالفعل يعني هناك العديد من
العوامل التي ادت الى ارتفاع عادات طالبي
اللجوء غير الشرعيه وهناك ضغط ايضا من
جراء الحرب الروسيه في اوكرانيا وارتفاع
اعداد اللاجئين الاوكرانيين
القادمين الى بريطانيا ورغم ان هؤلاء
اللاجئين يعني غير مشمولين باعداد طالبي
اللجوء غير الشرعيه الذين ياتون الى
بريطانيا عبر القناه الانجليزيه مثل
الافغان او الايرانيين او السوريين او حتى
الالبان ولكن هناك ارتفاع
يبدو بان الارتفاع هذا اساسه همم ارتفاع
في اعداد اللاجئين الالبانيين وذلك بسبب
يعني تحسن نظام الجريمه المنظمه في شمال
فرنسا ما بين الالبانيين وبالتالي هناك
العديد من هؤلاء الذين قدموا الى بريطانيا
خلال الاشهر او خلال هذا هذه السنه اعراب
اللاجئين هو تحسن لا هؤلاء بمعنى المافيات
ولكن هل بريطانيا تنظر الى الاجراءات
المتخذه فرنسيا على انها مقبوله او لا
يعني طبعا هذا هو الموضوع الاهم في ملف
اللاجئين لان بريطانيا تشعر بان فرنسا لا
تقوم بما يعني يجب فعله همم ردع هؤلاء من
العبور عبر القناه الانجليزيه وطبعا يعني
اذا نظرنا الى السبب الرئيسي لهذا الموضوع
هو برنس لان قوانين الاتحاد الاوروبي كانت
تتيح البريطانيا ما قبل خروج من يعني همم
الاتحاد الاوروبي اعاده اللاجئين الى
الدول الاوروبيه التي قدموا منها ولكن بعد
بركزه وبسب عدم وجود هذه القوانين وعدم
وجود اتفاقيات مع هذه الدول لا تستطيع
الحكومه البريطانيه اعاده هؤلاء اللاجئين
وفرنسا وبلجيكا مثلا من الدول التي لا
ترغب باستقبال اللاجئين من جديد وبالتالي
هي ترفض همم يعني همم ابرام صفقات من هذا
النوع من اجل اعاده هؤلاء الى اراضيه يعني
البديل والخيار رواندا بس عندي سؤال في ما
يتعلم العلاقات البريطانيه
الفرنسيه شاهدنا توتر شاهدنا ايضا مشدات
همم لفظيه اذا ما صحت تعبير ما بين
البلدين كيف تصفين هذه العلاقه الان
يعني طبعا هناك همم هناك الكثير من التوتر
بين بريطانيا وفرنسا فيما يخص ملف
اللاجئين همم كنت قد اشرت الى ان البديل
الذي تحاول بريطانيا فعله هو همم يعني
مساعده القوات القوات الحدود الفرنسيه في
ما يخص همم رضع اللاجئين من العبور عبر
هذه القناه راينا هناك صفقه بقيمه 64
مليون جنيه بين فرنسا وبريطاني وذلك من
اجل مساعده القوات قوات الحرس الفرنسي
لردعها هؤلاء اللاجئين من العبور عبر
القناه الانجليزيه وبالفعل يبدو انه هناك
كانت معلومات تشير الى بدء اول هذه عمليات
التعاون ما بين بريطانيا وفرنسا في هذا
الموضوع بالتحديد خاصه وان فرنسا كما ذكرت
هي ترفض همم ابرام صفقه مع بريطانيا همم
يعني تقوم بموجبها باعاده اعاده هؤلاء
اللاجئين الى اراضيها وبالتالي ايضا فيما
يتعلق باعاد وهم هناك حديث عن ارسالهم الى
رواندا وكان في محاكمات بهذا الاطار من
قبل همم جمعيات حقوقيه ترفض مثل هذا
التحرك اين وصل هذا الطرح في بريطانيا
عروب
طبعا كما نعلم بان وزيره الداخليه
البريطانيه من كان لها دور كبير في الضغط
على ترحيل اللاجئين من بريطانيا الى
رواندا بحسب اتفاقيه همم كانت قد ابرمتها
الحكومه البريطانيه مع الحكومه الرومانسيه
من اجل ذلك ولكن لم ااه يعني لم يتم اعاده
اي منها هؤلاء اللاجئين بعد ذلك بسبب بعض
العقبات القانونيه التي ترفض يعني اخراج
اللاجئين من بريطانيا
ولكن كما نعلم بان المحكمه البريطانيه قبل
تقريبا عده اسابيع قالت بان ترحيل
اللاجئين الى رواندا هو ترحيل قانوني
وبالتالي يعني يبدو ان هناك تمهيد هذه
العمليه بشكل جدي ااه لترحيلها هؤلاء الى
رمان
هذه
الطاقاتها من لندن عروب عبد الحق مراسله
العربيه شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه المعلومات
[موسيقى]
علق الاف المسافرين في المطارات الفلبينيه
بعد ما تسبب انقطاع في التيار الكهربائي
بين قطاع الاتصالات في مانيلا ادى الى
الغاء مئات الرحلات او الى تاخيرها او
تحويل مصاريها
[موسيقى]
اسطنبول
من صفاق هنتاي طب وسيم ولا بقى
[موسيقى]
عدا البعض في مدن سنيه رئيسيه منها بكين
شنغهاي ووهان لانشطتهم الطبيعيه على الرغم
من البرد وارتفاع حالات الاصابه بفيروس
كورونا متابعه
[موسيقى]
في حادث مؤسف وقع في استراليا اليوم لقي
اربعه اشخاص مصرعهم اصيب ثلاثه اخرون
بجروح خطيره في تصادم طائرتيه هليكوبتر في
الجو بالقرب من مقصد سياحي شهير في منطقه
جولد كوست بحسب ما افادت السلطات
الاستراليه نشاهد هذه الصور من الحادثات
[موسيقى]
العناوين التاسعه
مستشفى
اوكراني على دوناتس كواكب تقول العدد 10
اضعاف الاعلام
لقطع الامداد عن ميليشيات ايران تقرير
يكشف نيه اسرائيليه لتعطيل المطارات
الرئيسيه في سوريا
[موسيقى]
القضاء الايراني يثبت حكم الاعدام بحق
المتظاهر محمد بروغني والعفو الدوليه تدعو
طهران لالغاء العقوبه
البرلمان الليبي يعلن تكلفه فريق قانوني
للدفاع عن ابو عجيل المشتبه به بقضيه
لكرديه
التاسع انتهت الى طاهر الان و 360 طاهر
الاثنين الاسود على موسكو اضراب تونس
واصول رونالدو الى الرياض للالتحاق بناديه
الجديد النصر